avant de parler du mariage pour tous
adopté hier en lecture solennelle à
l'assemblée culture cinéma chaque
mercredi le diwan va recueillir vos
réactions à la sortie des salles nous
allons voir si cette semaine vous avez
été nombreux aux projections de légumes
des jours c'est le film du versailles
est d'origine ou michel gondry
l'histoire proprement dite est simple
mais bon pour les effets spéciaux c'est
c'est génial c'est génial et en 3d alors
c'est un ravissement excellent très
surprenant par rapport à la bande
annonce que j'avais vu en fait vraiment
beaucoup mieux que le deuxième plus
profond plus noir décide donc vraiment
très intéressant voilà c'était vraiment
très bien aller voir absolument
le film était pas mal beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux le personnage était
intéressant franchement c'est un petit
rayon de soleil c'était drôle j'ai bien
rigolé ça met de bonne humeur
franchement en plus le scénario est bien
écrit
le super c est ça représente bien ce
milieu là quads et des émigrés portugais
une certaine époque on va dire voilà un
film familial très agréable à regarder
je connaissais pas l'histoire bac pour
moi je suis pas rentré dedans tout de
suite ou et non le caje bien j'ai pas
tout compris mais enfin ça peut
intéresser quand même certaines
personnes pour moi c'est j'ai pas
accroché
voilà je ne suis pas senti les émotions
que je pensais ressentir je trouve je
pensais que l'univers de gondry
s'adapterait bien celui de brésiliens et
c'est pas parce que j'ai trop mécanique
ça manquait de poésie ça ne les a pas
pris avec moi en tout cas voilà à part
ça je peux pas dire que c'est un mauvais
film
elle affiche donc cette semaine les
cultes des jours de gondry le
réalisateur originaire des yvelines de
versailles signe l'adaptation du roman
de boris vian avec notamment au casting
notre yvelinois le trappistes omar sy
michel gondry un réalisateur qui a
affirmé son style ces dernières années
avec notamment la science des rêves ou
encore eternal sunshine et c'est romain
duris la tête d'affiche de l'écumé des
jours qui nous parle de sa manière bien
à lui du réalisateur d'aborder le
tournage dans tel film mais ça je le
sais déjà qu'il est fou oui je le savais
déjà et je pense qu'il faut un mec un
peu barge pour faire enfin marche
j'espère qu'ils quand même c'est que du
bon à ce que je dis mais il faut
quelqu'un qui a un culot un des idées
qui qu'ils bousculent des des du risque
à tout ça pour faire les clowns des
jours sinon on essaie de suivre
mot-à-mot ce qu'écrit boris vian et là
c'est je pense pas que ça ma sauce prend
prennent donc donc donc c'était plutôt
rassurant désir c'est l'équipe des gens
mais c'est michel gondry
c'est un nouveau cuisinier mon avocat et
mon maître à penser
une cuisine pour se calmer les nerfs
rendez-vous au frigo il faut que tu vois
mon piano'cktail à chaque note
correspond à l'alcool in ekker ou à la
roma
on l'obtient agosta gic pour un accord
miller a fait quatre fois ce matin
disons deux ou trois notes personnelles
alors j'ai rencontré quelqu'un enfin
c'est quand même très gaullien ce
sentiment de solitude
si j'existe de tomber amoureux est une
danse est convenable ce soir chez lui
oui mais si voix la voix la voix si oui
je comprends dit qu'une est-ce que je
peux partir s'il vous plaît
mais hors champ
je
c'est un peu court
ici mon coeur
ce
j'aime
je sens pas bien je voulais pas me dire
ce qui se passe je veux faire quelque
chose je suis pas le mari mais je fais
partie de l'équipe nénuphars dans le
poumon droit
un logis le prochain qui s'inquiètent
puis sentiment de toute ma vie dépend de
cet instant précis
je rate bon je pense au contraire tu
avis disant aux bijoux
cela m'a dit chloé qui nous anime
si on rate ce moment on essaie celui
d'après et si on échoue on commence
instants suivants on a toute la vie pour
réussir
je crois que le fait de jouer dans des
conditions un petit peu chaotique parce
qu'il ya tous ces éléments qui évoluent
autour d'eux qu'ils sont matériels et
qui sont compliqués à gérer
moi de mon expérience ça ça donne des
jeux des performances qui me plaisent
parce que les gens se retrouvent un peu
perdu mais dans le sens pas dans le sens
où on les voit pas dans le sens où ils
perdent contrôle de eux donc ils peuvent
plus réfléchir à ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire et se retrouve plus dans le
moment présent et et moi je trouve que
mes acteurs sont bien et donc ça me ça
me conforte dans la méthode